EVAN WITTENBERG: Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you very much for coming.
My name is Evan Wittenberg and I head up Global
Leadership Development
here at Google.
And it is my distinct honor and pleasure to
introduce and welcome my
former colleague and good friend, Professor
Mike Useem, to Google.
I've been trying to get Mike here for three
years, ever since I
started.
Mike is the Egan Professor of Management at
the Wharton School and has
been teaching there for 15 years or so.
And he also is the director of Wharton Center
for Leadership and
Change.
He's written countless books, all of which
get wonderful reviews and
are really good reads.
And I could talk to you all day about Mike
and what a great leader he
is and colleague he is, but I thought it would
be better to have
somebody who is a former student of Mike's
comes up and tell you a
little bit about him, so Gopi Kallayil, who
is the lead for the Product
Marketing Team for Search Advertising and
a former student of Mike's is
going to come up and do that part of the introduction.
Gopi Kallayil: Thanks, Evan.
In 2002, I had a momentary lapse of reason
and signed up for a
experiential leadership program that took
us all on an expedition to
Mount Everest base camp.
Due to political trouble in Nepal that year,
the expedition leader
decided to move the expedition to Mount Kanchenjunga
in the Himalayas.
It's the third highest mountain in the world
and extremely demanding.
The course was intended to be a experiential
leadership course, so the
first day, the leader of the program asked
me to be leader for a day.
And at that very first day, we were caught
in the midst of the worse
Himalayan storm had ever seen.
These fierce winds -- that's experiential
leadership with Matt Kolinsky
on the other end.
So we were caught on this worst Himalayan
storm ever seen with crazy
winds and sheets of ice everywhere.
One of the members of the group, Lynn Dan,
told me that evening, as she
was sitting in this tent about to blown away
that this was the first
ever night out in a tent --
[laughter]
-- and how terrified she was.
So these situations involve real -- in a difficult
life situations.
Because during that one day, I had to make
decisions that took into
account the safety and well-being of the other
members of the group,
the Sherpas, and even the yaks that carried
our baggage up the
mountains.
The leader of that expedition was Mike Useem.
And this is how he teaches his student leadership
but not by using two
by two metrics as -- but by actually putting
people in the midst of
difficult life situations where you have to
call for your leadership
that can effect the life and well-being of
other people.
I've had the pleasure, privilege, and honor
of being Mike's student at
the Wharton School of Business at the University
of Pennsylvania, where
as Evan mentioned, he's also the Director
for Center for Leadership and
Change.
And yes, Mike is a scholar.
He's the author of more than five books, including
his latest, which
he'll talk about today, "The Go Point: When
It's Time to Decide".
But what was endeared Mike to me as a teacher
is the fact that he's a
fantastic storyteller.
And the way he likes to teach leadership is
either by putting his
students in certain situations or making them
walk through the
leadership situations of other leaders who
may have led Everest
expeditions or led smoke jumpers or been in
civil war battlefields.
With that as an introduction, I'm delighted
to present before you Mike
Useem from the Wharton School.
Mike?
[applause]
MIKE USEEM: All right, everybody.
Good.
We're about to do this as a tandem.
Anyway, my privilege to be here.
I know this is a very brief opportunity for
us to have a dialogue and
we're really going to make it a dialogue.
So we're going to make this an active workshop,
be ready.
A couple people have helped me out with some
of your names.
So I know that Paul is sitting right over
here.
So, Paul, you'll be ready, right?
And right behind Paul I think is Jenny, right?
Okay.
So be ready, Jenny for a throwback of a dialogue
here.
I'm going to start this way.
The topic is making decisions.
And it's almost true by definition, if you
think about Meg Whitman,
maybe your future governor; or the current
governor; or John McCain; or
Hillary Clinton; or Barack Obama, people in
a position of leadership
responsibilities do have to be ready to make
and timely decisions.
Good and timely.
That's a formulation because often those two
criteria for decision
making work against each other.
In fact, we have a phrase to indicate maybe
one end of a spectrum.
If somebody "shoots from the hip," they've
made a decision that's fast
be it may not be very good.
Other end of the spectrum, analysis paralysis,
perfect decision.
It just took a long time to reach it.
We want to find the sweet spot somehow in-between.
We want it to be good and timely.
And that's the agenda I'm going to work with
you for literally about
35 minutes here.
It's going to work best, if you wouldn't mind,
since this is a
workshop.
If you would think now about the decisions
you have made, the decisions
people that you have admired in politics or
at this company or in the
community, they have made.
Start thinking about what makes for good and
timely decisions.
This is about making decisions when somebody
else is looking to you for
the leadership you are obliged to exercise.
To get us going, on the premise that I think
we often think about these
issues most tangibly, which also means most
memorably, if we can see
these ideas embedded in experience, your own
or that of others.
So I have a test here.
I'm going to ask Paul to see if he can answer
this question, Paul, or
Jenny for that matter, I challenge you -- I
think you're not going to
be able to answer this question to help us
remember who Gustavus W.
Smith is.
Gustavus W. Smith.
This is really a -- this is a tough one.
This is obscure.
But Jenny, you remember who Robert E. Lee
is right?
Confederate General Robert E. Lee, Paul, you're
okay on that?
Okay.
Strictly speaking, keep this in mind, Robert
E. Lee, one of the great
commanders of the Confederacy, was preceded
in office by a Gustavus W.
Smith.
I'd like you to see what he looked like.
This will help us focus on what we're referencing
here.
Gustavus Smith, upper left-hand corner.
I think everybody is just blanking.
You've thought about Jeb Stewart and Ulysses
S. Grant and Robert E.
Lee and George Mead, and Sheridan and Sherman,
but we're a little bit
stuck on Smith even though he was one of the
Confederacy's great
commanding officers.
And here's why he's totally forgettable: June
1st, 1862 -- it's a
tough to see map up there -- the United States,
in mortal conflict now
with the Confederacy which is created in 1861.
South Carolina quits, 11 -- 10 other states
joined to form the CSofA
the Confederate States of America, and in
the spring of 1862, the
United States, the 22 remaining states, decide
-- it decides to end the
Civil War, 1862.
It, of course, won't end until 1865, but the
U.S. decides to end the
war in 1862 or least it thought it could,
Abraham Lincoln presiding
leader of the moment, by sending a force -- arrow
on the right-hand
side of that photograph or that map rather
there -- from Washington
down to what is then called, still is called
Fort Monroe not to far
from Norfolk, Virginia, and to march up then,
still called the
Peninsula to attack Richmond, the capital
of the Confederacy.
The premise, a little bit false, but accepted
at the time is that if
you could capture Jefferson Davis, President
of the breakaway
Confederate States of America and take over
his White House in
Richmond, Virginia, maybe capture a good bit
of the defending forces,
that could end the Civil War.
That's the plan.
So 125,000 U.S. soldiers are landed are Fort
Monroe -- lower right-hand
corner in that map -- and they begin to march
in a northwestern
direction towards Richmond.
A little hard to see but it's in the upper
left-hand corner there.
If you're Jefferson Davis, you're concerned
about the army that's
defending the capital.
It's about 65,000 strong only, led by commanding
officer Joseph
Johnston, outnumbered 2 to 1.
Of course, you got home court advantage, Johnston
is defending
Richmond, home -- home field.
Still, 2 to 1.
It does not look maybe all that promising
for Jefferson Davis because
he knows if he's captured, he'll probably
be hung.
So there's a little bit of a personal concern
here not to mention his
concern about the future of the country that
leads him -- in an era
without any Nexus One telephones or even a
Blackberry, to go out to see
what's going on in the frontline.
It's hard to believe there was such an era,
but in 1862, May 31st, 1862
anyway, Joseph Johnston, the commanding officer
of the Confederate
force that is preventing the fall of Richmond,
the frontline of Joe
Johnston's defensive line around Richmond
is only about five miles from
the center of town -- Jefferson Davis, President,
rides out, this as if
Barack Obama decides to pick up and go to
Kandahar, Afghanistan, to see
what's going directly in the field.
That's exactly what Joe Johnston now has at
his back as his boss
Jeff Davis goes out to take a look.
Jefferson Davis, within a few feet of Joe
Johnston, sees Joe hit by
shrapnel and hit by a bullet at the same time.
This is May 31st, 1862, not fatal.
Jefferson Davis walks over and says something
like this, "Joe, you're
not looking too good right now".
And Joe says, "Well, sir, I've been -- maybe
mortally wounded, to tell
you the truth".
It's not but it's a very serious injury, and
so Joe Johnston is asked
by Jeff Davis -- Jefferson Davis, to show
the right respect here, is
asked who his replacement is that hopefully
will defend Richmond
against its eminent overrun by the United
States of America.
He says my number two guy, Gustavus W. Smith
is my able replacement.
Gustavus W. Smith, a career which actually
looks very good.
A bearing which is professional, sounded and
looked like, has a CV that
is very leadership-like as well.
Looks like a leader, acts like a leader, the
resume says it all, West
Point has risen up to the number two person
in the army that's
defending Richmond against it's eminent overrunning
by the United
States, he -- on the spot, this is a literal
statement now, gets a
battlefield promotion.
So Gustavus Smith, his boss down, Jeff Davis
walks over and says, "Gus,
you're it.
I hereby appoint you commanding officer of
the Army of Northern
Virginia and you're going to prevent my hanging.
I hope you got some ideas now to do that".
Gustavus Smith, this hand, gives a salute.
"Thank you for the battlefield promotion.
I've always wanted to be a commanding officer.
I'm going to write home about this my kids
are going to show me some
respect now".
At that point, Jefferson Davis says to Gustavus
W. Smith, "Gus, now that
you're in charge of saving the Confederacy,
what's your plan"?
And Gustavus Smith, keep in mind, he is number
two, this is as if Joe
Biden suddenly becomes President, he's probably
had to think about what
he's might to do, Gustavus Smith says, "Give
me a few minutes to think
about that, sir".
That's a little bit of a setback to his president.
Jefferson Davis wanders off, returns 24 hours
later, and says, "Joe --
Gus, rather.
Gus, you've had time now to give some thought
to your strategic plan,
what is it"?
And Gustavus W. Smith famously, or infamously,
says, "Sir, to tell you
the truth, I've got no plan.
Do you have any good ideas"?
Now, Jeff Davis had many well-known flaws,
one of which, though -- it
was not -- was he was able to make good and
timely decisions.
He said on the spot, "Gus, I hate to tell
you, but you are history".
Actually, the opposite.
But we use that phrase, you're history, you're
fired.
And Gustavus W. Smith becomes, in a sense,
part of our non-history,
completely forgotten.
But he is fired 24 hours later because Jefferson
Davis had a great
leader, a commanding officer of a huge army,
65,000 strong that when
all was said and given command, put in a leadership
position, could not
take command.
Unable to make a decision, unable to conjure
up a plan within which to
make decisions.
At this point, to finish off this account,
Jefferson Davis says to his
military aide standing right over here named
Robert E. Lee, Davis says
"Bob, are you busy right now"?
And Lee says, "Of course not, sir, whatever
you would like".
Robert E. Lee a long career in the Armed Services.
When the war begins he is still a colonel
which is a below a General
Officer, but now he's the military aide to
Jefferson Davis.
And on June 1st, 1862, here's the phrase -- Robert
E. Lee comes to
command, it's a phrase.
Jeff Davis says to Lee, "With Gustavus Smith
gone, I'd like you to
become the commanding officer of the Army
of Northern Virginia".
Lee takes command, didn't look a whole lot
different from Gustavus
Smith by way of resume, by way of deportment,
demeanor, you name it.
But the difference was Lee could make decisions
timely, never perfect,
but usually pretty good and Smith could not.
Hence, in the United States now there are
about 60 Robert E. Lee
elementary schools.
There are no Gustavus W. Smith elementary
schools.
And arguably one difference, among several,
is that Robert E Lee was
pretty good at the art of making good and
timely decisions.
Just to finish this off to make the point,
Lee takes command June 1st,
the forward observers for the Union Army called
the Army of the Potomac
can see the spires of downtown Richmond but
that's as close as they're
ever going to get.
Lee takes command makes a series of somewhat
-- sometimes flawed, but
usually very timely decisions and ultimately
pushes an army twice its
size away from Richmond, off the Peninsula.
And by the way, the Union Army -- it's a name
some of you will recall
-- the Union Army is commanded by a 34-year
old named George McClellan.
And McClellan, with twice the force that Lee
has, is defeated by Lee on
the Peninsula, Abraham Lincoln fires McClellan
for the first of two
times.
McClellan, a little bit also known for the
analysis paralysis.
One end of the pole.
He was a commanding officer, fantastic.
Soldiers loved him.
And they loved him in part because he would
wait until everything was
perfect before he would do anything with the
Army.
He had a case of analysis paralysis.
It was often said during that era, George
McClellan would like every
solider who ever worked for him to retire
as a veteran never having
fired a shot.
Because everything was not perfect ever for
McClellan before he would
finally issue an order to attack -- Lee had
-- did not suffer from
analysis paralysis.
He defeats McClellan on the Peninsula.
I know the prolongation of Confederacy is
not necessarily something we
admire, probably is not.
But the point I want to leave us with is the
difference between a
Robert E. Lee and Gustavus W. Smith is not
the ability to think
strategically, they were both pretty good
at that.
They both look like a leader ought to look,
call that demeanor.
But one of the enormous and enduring and historical
differences -- one
could make good and timely decisions, the
other could not.
My guess is many of you have worked for a
boss along the way.
You don't fit this description, but a boss
who was either suffering
from shooting from the hip or analysis paralysis,
one end of the
spectrum or the other.
We're going to work for a few minutes on getting
a formula to find the
sweet spot so we can make good and timely
decisions.
I'm going to add a couple thoughts from the
field of research and
experience on this, but before I do that,
Paul, if you can get us
going, I'm going to ask to you to use your
best stage voice so
everybody can hear.
What do you think defines for you personally
-- what is the factor that
helps you makes good and timely decisions?
PAUL: Sure, so I just made the comment that
what is good decision
making all about to me, it's a matter of having
confidence that you're
ready to make the decision.
When are you ready is when you have a well-thought
through rationale
that usually is data-based, and I think especially
at Google we prize
that, rather than just making decisions based
on emotions.
MIKE USEEM: But if you think about leadership
more generally, think
about yourself, think about people that lead
this company, the people
that you may work for, people who may work
for you, active listening is
a pretty good quality.
To hear what the customers want, what people
are looking for in terms
of value proposition, so hear what Paul has
said.
And now we're going to hear from Jenny in
an active listening sense.
JENNY: I have to agree with Paul, I think
data is a really important
factor in making any decision.
I think it would also be helpful to have a
vision and data that
supports both things that agree with that
decision and maybe aspects of
that vision that might not end up panning
out.
So data to support both sides.
MIKE USEEM: Great, Jenny, thank you.
Well-put.
At this point, I think I've give up on the
cold calling.
Thank you for being cold called and willing
to stand up here.
Who else would like to add a thought here
making good and timely
decisions?
This is going to get Rachel off the hook here,
if we can get somebody
to volunteer.
Rachel, I guess it's going to be you.
Would you mind?
Thank you.
RACHEL: I'd like to thank Gopi for giving
you my name.
I think an important quality and a good decision
maker is the ability to
look past the immediate impact and understand
how your -- how your
decision will influence the outcome further
down the road and being
able to plan for that and factor that into
your decision process.
MIKE USEEM: Great, very well-put.
Thank you on that one.
Anyone else want to volunteer a thought?
And I think there is some value -- there is
value in doing this.
It's pretty much your working philosophy,
we're all collectively
responsible.
And all of us can think better about just
about anything if we pool our
collective knowledge.
I think I see a hand here, oh, thank you.
Would you mind standing up with the microphone?
>> I think at a certain level you have to
comfortable with winging it.
MIKE USEEM: You do.
And say more about that.
>> Well, I mean, personally, my personal style
is I tend to have
analysis paralysis, but -- but because the
data -- you always want the
data to be complete.
And it's -- it's probably never complete but
in the short-term and the
timely side of things, it's really not complete.
So I guess if you're really on top of it,
and you're going to set up as
a good leader, you've probably done some preparation
beforehand, so you
kind of are already on the right track but
then you just wing it.
And stick to it.
MIKE USEEM: That's good.
Great.
Tell us who you are.
>> Oh, Sandra.
MIKE USEEM: Thank you very much.
Now, let's take these four great statements.
I'm going to add from the world of academic
research and a little
experience a couple more thoughts.
By the way, though, as we develop our framework
for making good and
timely decisions, it's a completely pointless
exercise if we can't take
those ideas and translate them into what we
do.
So we're going to worry a little bit about
taking ideas into action,
concept into behavior.
That's all a way of giving you the heads up,
we have a final exam
coming in about ten minutes.
So be alert.
I want you to use some of these ideas.
Here are a couple more thoughts to flesh out
or add to what you just
hear I'm going to skip over a couple items
here.
If anybody worked with John Chambers directly
over the years?
Okay, is he up the street or down the street
from here?
South, okay.
John Chambers.
He is a survivor, you know that.
1995 came to run Cisco Systems and he's pretty
well-known for many
things.
He's got a great stage presence, comes out
of marketing, knows how to
run an off-site.
He's also given to a pretty good record of
friendly acquisition.
Now you've done a lot of that.
He's got a record of building, partly organically,
Cisco from what it
was to what it is, but partly through many,
many always friendly
acquisitions.
Many companies are called to sell out to John,
few are chosen.
His track record, generally speaking by at
least academic assessment,
is pretty good for picking winners and avoiding
those that he should
not have acquired.
I had read that, ran into John Chambers at
an event a couple of years
ago.
And I offered up the following, "John, you're
pretty well known for
making good decisions when it comes to acquisition,
what's your secret"?
And this is what he offered up.
He said, "Well, let's see, proposal comes
my way from my strategy team,
the investment bank, our outside advisor has
given us an evaluation
that we ought to be ready to pay up around
-- and then my secret is the
following: Before I decide -- and it's always
these are binary, either
we buy or we don't -- I turn to my two secret
weapons, Larry Carter and
John Morgridge".
Larry Carter, Chief Financial Officer; John
Morgridge, former CEO and
now non-executive, at that time, couple years
ago, Chair of the Board.
Larry Carter is gone but at the time he was
CFO.
I said, "Okay, well when you turn to them
what's the deal"?
And he says, "Investment bank has done its
thing, strategy team has done
its due diligence, and then I say, 'Larry,
what do you really think?
Is this a good deal for us or not'?
And then I turn to Morgridge, 'John, what
do you think'"?
And then John Chambers completely stumped
me.
Stopped me on the spot, when he said the following:
"I go to Larry and
I go to John Morgridge because they know the
company, number one, as
well as I do.
I get a second extremely informed opinion,
and equally importantly,
they don't want my job".
And I'm thinking, what does that have to do
with getting a good piece
of internal advice?
So I said, "John, what do you mean by that"?
So what did he mean by that?
So to use a scientific phrase, they're not
kissing up, so more
objective.
[off microphone]: They don't want to see you
fail.
MIKE USEEM: Now that's such a statement.
Actually bold statements are amazing.
You want somebody who's not trying to ingratiate
himself or herself,
you want somebody that is not ready to see
you fail so they can get
your job.
Such an amazing -- can you imagine a Chief
Financial Officer who
wouldn't give you good, honest fully disclosing
advice?
I guess we've said we know human nature enough
to know that personal
self-interest gets in the way of good decision
making.
That's a way of saying, and here's now a principle
for making good and
timely decisions, having somebody at your
elbow, well-informed, but
able to give you unbiased, non-self-serving,
catholic with a small "C"
line of advice.
A professional colleague of mine has taken
this into the research
terrain, I offer up her formulation very briefly
here.
If you've been through the Stanford Engineering
Program or the B
school, that is, I think, up the street here,
you may have run into
Kathy Eisenhardt?
Has anybody worked with Kathy Eisenhardt?
This is what she did.
Great study.
She went out in this vicinity, found a bunch
of hardware and software
makers, put them into two buckets: The slow
movers and fast movers.
Slow movers would take eight months to get
a product out the door that
the fast movers would take four months.
The product was no better, just took more
time.
By the way, which bucket is Google in?
Okay.
The fast movers -- I see some -- super fast.
You're over, actually, way over on this side
of the screen.
So let's see -- take a look at that third
bullet right there, one of
the findings, inductive.
She's like an ethnographer in anthropology.
What's the difference between the fast movers
and the slow movers?
And she found that the fast movers tended
to have decision makers like
your own, like you, who had on the inside
-- look at the phrase, an
experience counselor -- unbiased, non-self-serving,
not an outside
McKenzie or BCG or Bain but an insider.
Take a look at the next one.
This breaks my heart coming from Quaker Philadelphia,
where consensus
is king or queen, she found that at the fast
movers, they were ready to
take action without 100 percent consensus
being formed around the
decision yet to be made.
Partial consensus.
I've another way of getting at this and if
you look very carefully for
extra credit, you can find Evan Wittenberg,
on screen here.
[off microphone]: Just right of center.
MIKE USEEM: Yeah, just a little bit right
of center, crouching down,
your own Evan Wittenberg.
This is the learning formula so to speak that
we acquire when we take
our MBA students, 90 strong, twice a year
for a day and a half with the
U.S. Marine Corps.
We do that not to turn them into Marines,
we still want our tuition to
be paid for two full years.
We do this so that we can learn about good
and timely decisions under a
lot of pressure which is the what the Marine
mission is all about.
Get in, get the job done, do it well, and
get out.
And Evan and others here are hearing a four-point
formulation.
Good and timely decision making check it out.
Just look at the statements here.
Number one, an officer -- this goes back to
what we were just talking
about -- an officer goes for 70 percent assured-ness,
70 percent
confidence, 70 percent due diligence, 70 percent
agreement.
Not 50, but not 99.
70 percent, a little bit of an artificial,
overly specified measure.
Ann Livermore, some of you have worked with
her over at Hewlett
Packard, she often talks 60 percent.
It doesn't matter.
It's a metaphor for getting a lot of the way
there but not letting
perfect get in the way of a timely decision.
Look at the next line, learning to be totally
clear-minded to the staff
that works for you.
Unambiguous about intent.
Don't try to micromanage, assuming you got
great people on your team.
That leads to the third statement there, which
is this: You have to
develop a tolerance for error.
It's obvious.
If we're going for 70 percent confidence,
analysis, we're going to make
mistakes.
You have to develop a tolerance for errors.
But there's a caveat on that, not stated,
but it's pretty obvious.
Allow people who work for you to make an error
once, ask them to report
to you that they won't make that error again
because now they know
about the error of their way, so error, first
time, a great source of
schooling.
Second time, that's a serious mistake that
we can't allow to stand.
Mistakes are tolerated, first time.
Fourth statement is this: Indecisiveness is
fatal.
I'll make that a little bit more softly put,
in a position of
leadership, if you are indecisive you have
unequivocally probably taken
the wrong vow for your career.
Now this is a bit of a formulation.
I said we're coming to a final exam here.
Have we missed anything by way of -- and I
tend to call it a template,
a set of guidelines for yourself, we've had
four people describe
theirs.
Here are a couple thoughts prior screen from
the world of academe, U.S.
Marine Corps, is there anything else that
we ought to keep in mind when
it comes to guiding ourselves and how to make
good and timely
decisions?
Yes?
[off microphone]: I think preparations are
key to making decisions no matter how often.
MIKE USEEM: You're going to have to walk up
here and get you on the
air.
[PAUSE]
>> Yeah.
I've found preparation as being one of the
key to making
decisions no matter how often I face that
situation.
Is this the first time?
If it is the first time, I think you look
for more data but if I've
been in that situation before, you'll be able
to ask the right
questions.
And also I've been able to integrate probabilities.
How much information do you need to be more
than 50 percent right?
Do you need 100 percent information?
With this information, can you be confidence
that you're 70 percent
right at least.
And then you can make the decision.
MIKE USEEM: Let me pick up on that.
Many of you have read the great book by Malcolm
Gladwell called Blank
It's All About Decision Making.
He makes -- there's a secondary point in there
which is sometimes
overlooked that intuition is extremely valuable
but it's only as good
as it's informed by your past experience.
And my own view, the best people out there
for making decisions are
those that look back on decisions they have
made and others have made,
and you stick that into the back of your intuitions
so that it's
informed intuition.
After action review, looking back on everything
-- I'll make this very
tangible, going to come to final exam now
in 60 seconds.
I interviewed the Chief Executive a couple
years ago of Lenovo, big PC
maker who bought the IBM PC line back in '05.
World's fourth largest PC maker these days,
Liu Chuanzhi is his name, I
said how did you ever get into running a company
because you began as a
computer scientist for the Chinese Academy
of Sciences?
And he says, I got a pretty good intuition
because every Friday, I sit
down with whoever reports to me, we go over
every decision during the
week.
What was good, what was flawed, how can we
do better next week.
No formal training, no MBA, no nothing.
But self-training created an intuition which
has been pretty good.
Final exam, here we go.
Take all that we've said, I'm going to take
us to a fateful day.
1865 -- I'm going to skip over a bunch of
things here.
It's going to make you a little bit dizzy.
Pardon me on this.
Oh, wow, we're getting dizzy here.
Fateful day.
This is April 9th, 1865, Robert E. Lee survives,
wins on the Peninsula
back in 1862, never gives up command.
Lincoln was replacing generals every few months.
Once Lee takes command, and remember the date,
June 1st, 1862, he never
gives up command because he was as good as
they come.
But he's defeated finally near Appomattox,
Virginia.
April 9th, 1865, Lee surrenders.
Many paintings, no photographs.
I've got one shown here.
He surrenders to Ulysses S. Grant.
Grant, in his wisdom, sends a telegram to
President Lincoln, I have the
privilege of announcing to you that the South's
biggest army, led by
one Robert E. Lee, has unconditionally surrendered
today, Appomattox
Courthouse, Virginia.
What's Lincoln's next thought?
Put yourself in the mind of the man now in
the White House when you
hear -- when you read that telegram comes
over from the War Department,
what's your first thought?
What should be your first thought as the leader
of the country?
>> Hooray!
[laughter]
MIKE USEEM: Celebrate the end of four years
of absolute human carnage
and the fact that the Union now has been restored.
And to focus on that, having fought -- this
was almost total war for
its era: Think Atlanta, think Sherman's Campaign.
We now have to reconcile.
That's up in Washington back to Appomattox,
Virginia, in an odd move
Ulysses S. Grant picks a non-career officer
who had taken leave from
Bowden College where he was teaching English
and Speech, a guy named
Joshua Lawrence Chamberlain, anybody from
Maine will know that name.
And he says, Grant to Chamberlain, a midlevel
officer temporary, he
says, Chamberlain, on April 12th, I'm going
to give you the historic
distinction of the formal surrender of the
army of Robert E. Lee.
I order you to do the following: You're going
to stand at the edge of
a field, 4,000 men in blue and a few women
are going to be at attention
behind you.
This is ceremonial now, three days later after
the signing, and all the
Confederate units, a day of ignominy, have
to come up to where you're
standing, they have to give you their flag,
what's called the colors
for their unit and their weapons.
You have to take them.
Everything else is up to you.
So here's the final exam.
Got to think of -- we're almost out of time,
got to think about this
quickly, you're Chamberlain, you've been given
the intent.
Go back to that Marine Corps formulation but
all the decisions now
within that intent are up to you.
So how would you script the formal surrender
of Robert E. Lee's army?
What would you do?
Somebody give us a quick voicing.
I'll put it on the air here.
Well, it depends on what you want to achieve.
What's the point of the surrender?
Yes?
[off microphone]: Welcome home.
MIKE USEEM: The statement here is welcome
home.
And that is almost a perfect way to sum it
up.
We hereby defeat you but the objective of
this war was not to do that
but was to bring you back home.
So today is a day is a moment of reconciliation.
Now we've got to take that and bring that
down tactically.
So we're going to make a decision to reconcile
not humiliate.
We've got to bring that down tactically.
And let me just reference how that is done
with the following final
image, and we're now through the final exam
successfully completed.
These are the 4,000 soldiers lined up here.
This is Chamberlain, the temporary officer
from Maine, hard to see but
in the lower left-hand, almost speck place
of this image is the first
Confederate unit that's coming up a day of
ignominy, as far as they're
concerned.
Chamberlain, without permission, but that
was Lee's -- that was Grant's
purpose -- get the intent, you make the decisions,
tells a subordinate
"Carry Arms."
Many of us know the term "Present Arms."
It's a formal military posture, carry arms
one notch below that in
parade formation, but only given when you
want to show respect.
Great respect, normally only given to a Union
Officer, a General who's
come on to the scene.
Chamberlain tells his number two guy "carry
arms."
The word goes down, the 4,000 people so displayed
suddenly move,
musket comes over here, left hand across the
stock, the Confederate
Officer coming down that muddy lane, same
tradition.
They all come out of West Point more or less,
says to himself, whoa,
carry arms.
I guess that's -- that's for us.
So he in turn, still a little bit of authority
left.
They're about to be disbanded.
He turns to his own subordinate number two
officer and says "carry
arms."
In the history of the Civil War, this becomes
known as the salute
returning the salute.
And in the years after the end of the war,
you mention the name Sherman
anywhere in Georgia and people are going to
get red in the face all
over again.
Some of you I know are from the South.
If you mention the name Chamberlain, those
who knew about this incident
would say, Chamberlain, he was one of those
people that displayed us
with respect.
Let's see what does Lincoln want?
He wants to bring them back in.
That's the intent.
No evidence that Chamberlain ever met Abraham
Lincoln, but with that
intent known, reconciliation is required,
a decision is made April 12th
by Chamberlain for respect to be displayed
towards the defeated
Confederate Army.
Maybe that's the way -- one way to sum this
up, decision making.
Think the Marine Corps four-point formulation,
think Kathy Eisenhardt's
five part formulation, think the four people
who nicely reported what
they put into their decisions, read books
like Malcolm Gladwell on
that, and maybe to all that how about this
as a final parting shot,
don't you want people working for you when
they make good and timely
decisions ultimately to think like a president,
to think like you own
the company, to think that everything hangs
on you?
And I think that with a guideline, hopefully
people working for you in
their own leadership, will give you what you
want and what the company
needs.
My pleasure, may you all decide.
Thank you very much.
[applause]